on va plus loin avec alexis poulain sur
l'actualité politique de la journée avec
notre éditorialiste donc
alexis c'est la rubrique édito
[Musique]
bonsoir alexis manuel macro 1 de retour
des émirats et qui repart immédiatement
en campagne à la campagne aujourd'hui à
vierzon demain dans dans l'allier est la
rencontre peut-être deux de ses futurs
électeurs en tout cas peut-être
l'espère-t-il en secret même s'il n'en
son effort oui alors est clairement de
retour des émirats là c'est plutôt
rendez vous en terre inconnue c'est
emmanuel macron dans cette france
périphérique qu'il ne connaît pas il a
été critiqué pour être ce président des
riches le président hors sol c'est une
france qu'il a du mal à rencontrer à
connaître et de par laquelle il n'est
pas forcément aimer et on voit bien que
depuis septembre depuis ces annonces à
marseille emmanuel macron essaie de
colmater toutes les brèches en fait de
sa candidature toutes les fautes les
défauts qui pourraient avoir pour être
le candidat parfait et donc essayer de
rencontrer les gens de faire des tours
de passe-passe de distribuer de l'argent
notre argent et puis de faire campagne
en rencontrant tous les gens qui
pourrait lui dire qu'il a oublié tous
ces gens là pendant son quinquennat
enfin les gilet jaune qui étaient
nombreux à vierzon c'était une des
premières villes 1 de ce mouvement
n'oublierons pas le nombre des
manifestants gilet jaune qui ont été les
borniers la violence d'état qui s'est
abattue sur eux je crois que ça sert à
rien d'essayer de rabibocher des gens
qui ont été traités de cette façon là
par emmanuel macron alors il n'y a pas
que emmanuel macron qui cherche à parler
à la france des périphéries un eric
zemmour aussi rejoints par les figures
des gilet jaune comme jacqueline moreau
benjamin cauchy ça sera d'ailleurs notre
invité dans quelques instants avec
jérôme rodriguez et bien sûr là la
france insoumise avec toujours
évidemment comme stratégie le
recrutement des abstentionnistes oui on
voit bien qu'on est en campagne
électorale puisque c'est s'est oublié un
permanent de la politique sont en train
d'être un peu draguer par toulon d'alors
eric zemmour si vous voulez adhérer la
reconquête il ya même un anglais
français dans la précarité ou dans
difficulté vous pouvez donc payer
uniquement 10 euros un plus tôt que 50
euros également si vous êtes étudiant
donc je suis allé voir le site
incroyable incroyable mais ça reste
quand même dix euros quand vous êtes
dans la difficulté c'est quand même une
somme et puis évidemment l'idée c'est de
dire avec jacquet de moore avec benjamin
cauchy l'ale politique d gilet jaune
puisqu'il s'était déjà présenté faisait
déjà de la politique a rejoint eric
zemmour il faut voir que
sociologiquement les gilets jaunes sont
quand même une foule qui rejette le jeu
partisan parce que il ya quand même
quelque chose de l'ordre du système chez
eric zemmour on trouve les mêmes
financiers que chez emmanuel macron par
exemple ça n'a échappé à personne donc
il y a des limites à tout ça et puis
chez jean luc mélenchon lui c'est l'idée
de d'essayer de capter les voix des
abstentionnistes de dire que si jamais
tous les gens qui ne votent pas
d'habitude aller voter on parle de
millions de voix ça changerait
totalement la donne d'une élection et
c'est vrai qu'en ce moment on voit que
tout est possible sondage après sondage
dans finalement maintenant les candidats
sont connus mais emmanuel macron n'est
pas encore déclaré candidat et on voit
bien qu'il est certes en campagne mais
que chaque est en train de préparer sa
compagne et à gauche injustement elle
écrit vous en avait déjà un petit peu
parlé de cette gauche toujours dans le
flou des voies plus qu'est parce si on
en croit effectivement les sondages oui
le dernier sondage est là bas alors à
prendre avec des pincettes parce que du
matin au soir valérie pécresse prend 4
millions de voix elle passe de
la technique des sondages c'est le
prendre c'est que c'est en ligne il ya
toujours une marge d'erreur on peut les
critiquer mais il donne quand même
globalement une idée de température est
la température aujourd'hui en france on
voit bien que le camp de droite la
droite traditionnelle est en train de
reprendre de la vigueur à suite au
congrès et valérie pécresse devance eric
zemmour ce n'était pas forcément gagné
il ya quelques mois et puis maintenant
eric zemmour est au coude à coude avec
marine le pen et modèles macro est en
train de descendre une grignotera pas
plus finalement que ces 23 25% donc sur
un second tour tout est possible si un
candidat de la droite des républicains
si valérie pécresse arrive à passer et
qu'elle arrive à fédérer une partie des
électeurs dire examu remet
millions de voix ça voudrait dire qu'ils
auraient beaucoup de voix d'électeurs de
gauche aujourd'hui on est loin de ce
rassemblement là autour de valérie
pécresse donc des sondages encore à
prendre avec des pincettes mais qui
montre quand même un débat fortement à
droite pour cette présidentielle de 2022
merci à l'équipe audard